in pulp fiction there's a moment where
Bruce Willis character goes to buy some
cigarettes and he says to the bartender
he says 1 pack of red apples and the
bartender says filters and he says none
and that's just a really cool fast
interesting exchange there as opposed to
5 lines to explain what brand of
cigarettes he wants and oh you know what
how about no filters in those cigarettes
you know because it's very Norrish feel
it's very you know clipped and dark and
tight and it's just filters none and
that just gets the the idea across
said Claude Rains in Casablanca says to
Bogart he says what what brought you to
Casablanca and Bogart says the waters
and and it's a desert and Booker says
something like I was mistaken I was
misinformed
I was missing which is great dialogue
just great dialogue music it's music you
know which is the difference between
speak like we're doing here and an
interesting dialogue an interesting
dialogue good writing good script the
scripts at command attention is with an
extraordinary capacity to engage your
reader and that's usually through really
smart dialogue
the biggest problem with dialog is that
writers often make it carry the burden
of the story when what you want to do is
you want to tell the story visually it's
we're screenwriters not speaker writers
there's a reason for that so you want to
tell the story visually and use the
dialogue as icing on the cake
once the dialogue doesn't have is that
doesn't have the burden of telling the
whole story the dialogue can play can be
fun I mean it's still giving us parts of
the story but it's not carrying the
whole story so you know if you look at
if you watch a movie and look at a great
movie often great movies have so much
stuff that is dialogue free they're the
I think it's Billy Wilder who did this
and the story goes to Billy Wilder who
was a great German screenwriter came to
the United States when the Nazis took
over Germany and was sleeping on Peter
Laurie's couch
like many screenwriters Quentin
Tarantino was sleeping on Scotty
spiegel's couch and Scotty Spiegel got
him a screenwriting job so that it could
get him the hell off his couch so Peter
Lorre wanted to get Billy wild here the
hell off his couch and hooked him up but
went to Paramount Pictures and pitched
him as the greatest visual storytelling
screenwriter and so they had a scene and
I want to say it's in dodsworth but I
could be wrong where it was a 10-page
scene where a husband and wife have a
argument and through the argument we
find out that the their relationship is
no longer romantic or emotional in any
way they're just two people that live in
the same house and so there's 10 pages
of dialogue and they needed to cut it
down and Billy Wilder turn that into a
half page scene and the half page scene
was husband and wife on the elevator of
their building husbands wearing his hat
wife's got a purse clutched to her chest
doors open
pretty woman gets on the elevator
husband takes off the hat and smiles at
her you know and the wife basically
takes a step away from the husband that
scene gives us pretty much all the
information that the thrill is gone from
this relationship without all that
dialogue and so always be looking for
the scene that can demonstrate what's
going on in the story rather than tell
us through dial
that doesn't mean you have to get rid of
dialog but it does mean that the dialog
can now be something else can now have
fun first thing you have to understand
about dialog is that it's got to be
connected to the characters desire line
in the scene in other words if the
character has an objective your
intention in the scene the dialogue has
to match that intention and what I see a
lot of times especially with exposition
and information is that a character is
saying all that information and you can
tell that it's really the writers
objective in other words the writer once
tune wants the audience to know this
information because they think okay the
audience needs to know this and this and
this and this so the characters gonna
say this in this in this list and that
doesn't work because scenes and dialogue
are about a character's intention in the
scene everything a character says is
matched to what that desire line is so
anything that doesn't belong to that
doesn't fit and you can tell whether
it's the writer wanting to that
information wanting the audience not
information whether it's part of the
character
good trick is to try and keep your
sentences as short as possible which
forces you to write in a punchy er
fashion that's that's something that
that I guess I learned from my
journalist father although honestly I
tend to break that rule a lot so I'm
probably a bit hypocritical there
writers would constantly have a great
line at the end of a scene but then they
add a couple of more lines there in
security lines they call them so we
instantly just cross them out because
they already had a great line that's the
end of the scene
and yes everything hasn't been quite
wrapped up but that's that adds energy
when you cut that you're pouring energy
into the story when you leave it there
you're sucking energy out of the story
because the audience is like bored
through those last two lines and going
or do we need that I was I'm out of it
it you know you had me at a low kind of
you know you don't need that beginning
sentence you know you're saying the same
thing in repetition two lines from now
you know really getting concise down to
the point of having or overriding where
characters say something and you could
say it would be better if they just had
a reaction you know always try to err on
the side of let it let the actors act
and emote rather than say something you
know if you see someone's eyes 60 feet
on the screen that's gonna say a lot
more than a line of dialogue you know so
you cut cut cut cut cut cut they say cut
the dialogue and then cut it 20% more
than that you're like oh lean and no one
wants to because but I've read
screenplays that read like a stage play
and you're like that's not that's not
what this is or scenes every director
I've worked with said give me something
to shoot where the scene is just
flattens and two people sitting that
Quentin Tarantino can do it with the
interesting dialogue with ten pages of
dialogue but two characters sitting in
the dinner scene you know the directors
I worked with is they hate it they're
lazy what are we doing it's just this
this this you know and plus the food
would be spoiled you know it's it takes
a long time to film it you know there's
an old rule that you leave you enter a
scene as late as possible and you leave
it as early as possible and you make
sure that you hit the main
point of that scene and if you keep that
in mind that will also tend to focus
your dialogue
cut to the chase what's going on you
know less is always more is you know
what I mean and I've always found that
and you find producer I worked with he
caught the repetition and dialogue and I
didn't even see it and he said you're
saying the same thing here again we
don't need it I'm like oh my god you're
right and he's a big anti repetition you
know producer and I've never had that
before a producer like would point out
those specifics like oh you're right
I've got this bad habit now of not even
seeing it and so now I'm very cognizant
of that when I work with him and in
general that you know we only have so
much time on the screen and so many
pages and and if you don't like the
constraints then write a novel we can do
whatever you want but if you like the
screenplay format you know you have to
have these dense packed scenes with
subtext but not go on for six eight
pages you know there's a rhythm to it
you have a feel like you say when you
start reading that the scripts
overwritten and you just know
everything's described in the writers so
afraid to let go that their their vision
or their ideas won't come through on the
page well once they take that script and
make it yeah but you want to you know
your imprint is the script so you know
all these other little particulars are
not going to help when it's overwritten
in listening to how real people talk it
doesn't mean you're transcribing it
exactly you know people don't talk like
they're in a movie but so there is a
certain amount of you know dramatic
license that you have to use but you can
write to cinematically you know you can
write to theatrically into too much like
your characters are on stage and that
can come through on the page and that
can really hurt your script I mean what
I do is I tend to be the hero you know
in in the first sharknado I didn't know
I am ziering was gonna play fin
so that character was just me what would
I do if I were thrown into this insane
this situation and so then I I write as
my ideal self what would I like to say
in in that situation what would I like
to do you know because in in everyday
life we all have these moments where
somebody says something to us and we
just go and we don't know what to say
and then ten minutes later it comes to
you what you should have said to that
person and the beauty of screenwriting
is you can wait ten minutes until you
figure it out and then write it down to
write a good line of dialogue sometimes
it'll take me three weeks and then ten
drafts later I'm still tweaking that
that come back think about it as you
have a fight with your friend and then
you sit there in the shower kind of
replaying that and you keep coming up I
should have said that like like that's
what movies are that they're the writer
has gotten that perfect response so you
have this perfect back-and-forth
repartee that real life never has if any
if people in real life talk the way they
do in the movies these will be crazy
people you know but in the movies it's
okay it's expected you know in
storytelling so the idea of of
everything being honed to be
entertaining to be compelling to be a
feast it's it's a story is a feast as
opposed to just running through the
frigerator open the door and grab a few
things that's real life some of the keys
to good dialog people want to have now
sounding dialogue the problem with
natural sounding dialogue is if you were
to go I took a class once where they
said go record people in the wild so I
went to a mall and recorded people and
what I got the most interesting thing I
got was a guy who spoke entirely in
belches and you can understand him but
what happens in the war in the wild
humans in the wild when we speak we talk
and talk and talk and never get to the
point and that's a problem is in real
life real dialogue seems to never go
anywhere so what we don't want is real
dialogue we want something that appears
to be real dialogue and that means we're
gonna craft something so that it sounds
real one of the ways to do that is to
have characters misunderstand each other
because bad dialogue in movies is when
every character knows exactly what the
other character is thinking when they
say that in real life we don't know what
the other character is saying so if you
say I'm sick of your job I'm sick of you
working your job we may hear I'm sick of
you and respond to that we come up with
our response sometimes before the end of
the sentence so misunderstandings occur
in real dialogue and we create that I
have a USA Network movie called hard
evidence which is only memorable because
it was released on video after showing
on USA Network a million times on the
same day as a Julia Roberts movie called
something to talk about both came out
from Warner Brothers and my movie out
rented it in the nation and I have no
idea why except I did also see the Julie
Roberts movie was wasn't all that hot
but one of the things that happens in
that script is it's about a guy who
cheats on his wife and while he's
cheating on his wife his mistress says
she sells medical supplies but actually
what she is is a drug courier and in the
course of the story he she asked him to
carry the gun to their meet because she
usually goes with her boss and don't
worry my boss has been there a million
times again although stays in the pocket
never comes out they go to meet do the
exchange and the guy they meet pulls out
a badge and says I'm with the DEA
you're busted and she says shoot him and
he goes shoot him I can't shoot him and
she and basically she says he's just
claiming his with the DA it's not real
shooting and so she eventually helps the
husband shoot the guy and then the
husband has to go home to his wife and
pretend like nothing happened and so
he's not just covering up the mistress
he's now coming up the mistress and the
murder well the wife thinks the
husband's acting strange and decides to
follow him and follows him as he goes to
meet his mistress because he's freaked
out about this whole thing goes to talk
to the mistress about it because she's
only when he can talk to he can't talk
to his wife so the wife sees the
mistress puts two and two together and
confronts the husband and says you know
I know that you're sleep in her
confronts the husband says I know what
you did he's like then she it's you're
sleeping with this woman he's like oh
you know it's only the mistress and so
she basically says you know you're gonna
sleep on the sofa from this point on or
you know we're breaking up so he goes
down they get into an argument he sleeps
on the argument he's he's the one that
cheated so he's sleeping on the sofa and
the wife comes in one morning while he's
in the kitchen and says this is after a
period of time has passed and said that
sofa can't be too comfortable what does
he think she means he thinks she means
you can come up to the bedroom again so
he says so are you saying I can come up
to the bedroom again
that's his misunderstanding she says no
I'm calling my lawyer we're getting a
divorce you got to be out of here by
sundown so by creating that
misunderstanding
it seems real so think about how to
create misunderstandings where one
character hears things different or
hears what they want to hear and then
they respond to what they want to hear
and then they get the twist in there is
the reality so dialogue can now play you
know when you when it's not carrying the
burden of the story dialogue can play
dialogue can go down tangent places
characters can say more amusing things
a lot is said with that being said at
all there's always that you know and
subtext is very important in your
writing so you're not just you know
you're not just you you know it's not
just the dialogue has like some depth to
it and and what your exact what they're
saying is not necessarily what they mean
you know they're saying a to really mean
B because they're there their intention
to see you know there's that so there
are different layers to the to the
dialogue and sometimes honestly you
don't know know about that until you
write it and until you look look back on
it and say wow that was kind of
interesting or like that speech didn't
really go in the direction I thought it
would and yet it's kind of an
interesting twist you know but you just
try to make it real you try to make it
the way real people interact in real
situations if it's that kind of
certainly it's that kind of movie
you can learn a lot about how people
speak just by sort of listening like
listening in coffee shops to how people
talk and stuff people rarely are very
self-reflective people rarely say
exactly what they mean
people rarely talk in complete sentences
and so you know the words we choose when
you think about when you go to say
something there's probably a hundred
different ways you could think of to say
it why are you choosing the particular
way you you choose and when you start to
think like that and why your character
is choosing to say something that way
and what they really don't want to
reveal like why ye will they go to this
length but they won't go just a little
bit more vulnerable when you kind of
understand that about your character
then I think writing the dialogue
becomes easier but you have to put that
thought process into it first to know
what they want to conceal and what they
want to to give I think and then and
then you can start working with the
subtext and all that kind of stuff that
makes all of that flavor kind of come
out subtext generated in probably two
ways one is if this topic of your scene
is why are you cheating on me as it
sometimes is say with harsh and Carol
you have them talk about anything but
that in a way and in a context so harsh
and Carol
talking about their marriage whilst to
res is in the other room
and overhearing things you do it in that
way you you go off point of a
conversation you have a conversation
about how difficult it is to repair the
damn plumbing or whatever but and you do
that in order to make your point very
clear which is dammit this is this is
wrong all of this is wrong and the other
way which is really a one of my favorite
ways is to just describe behavior in a
certain context so Carolyn Torres riding
in a car what is she looking at what is
she doing what is this what's what's
actually going on and none of it has
anything to do with why don't know
camera angles or anything like that it's
just about what's happening which is the
basis of all drama whether it's a
screenplay or or play how people inhabit
a space at a certain time that's it it
seems almost laughably simple or easy
but it rarely makes it intact to a
screen in the way that that this has
enhanced greatly by the Me's own sin and
and and the performances and everybody
in every department just working to
preserve a fundamental truth about a
piece of material ultimately it is about
a character wanting something right
every story is about a character wants
them wanting something and then facing a
conflict to get it whether they get it
or not
so when they want something they have a
desire that desire is expressed through
subtext if I want this glass of water
I'm going to take the action right so
the subtext is that you can infer I'm
thirsty or I'm looking for some sort of
like physical distraction to keep my
hands busy or something like that
[Music]
and the gulping is part of that too sure
maybe there's I'm about to confront you
on something
yes you know or I'm your boss or you
know whatever I'm an ex-girlfriend me
there's just so many things and anything
you're like you know yeah exactly she's
gonna say to me so a lot of that is
about interpreting we we are guessing
what a character wants from the
behaviors they're exhibiting right now
the context is simply the worldview the
situation they're dealing with right so
we're sitting in a room right now we
have we all have different objectives
and so that this the when the character
so the context is literally just like
the plate that you're serving everything
on like I compare it like visually it
came up with the metaphor of creme
brulee just use a visual metaphor where
you've got the plate as the context and
then you've got the brulee or the the
creme the cream as the subtext and then
the the top layer that's burned and
scorched brûléed is the text oh that's
great so the idea is basically what
we're seeing is words right and those
words often are in complete
contradiction of actual intention but in
some way were interpreting those words
as a kind of behavior so most of the
time like for example it's part of the
reason when I'm writing the last thing I
do is write dialogue that was another
thing I learned from wrong media you
want to be able to well do whatever you
want but for me I like to have the
characters intentions very clear and the
conflict that they're gonna be facing
very clear and what we're constantly
trying to do is there's this one there's
a one book called character and
viewpoint where it talks about how
essentially you know we're all like
chimpanzees in the wild and when they're
in when they're in the jungle and they
sense that there's a threat they run
away and the first thing they do as soon
as they feel like they're safe the very
first thing they do is they stop they
turn around
see where the source of danger is so
that's when they're completely engaged
the whole chimpanzee metaphor is
basically that we're trying to interpret
the intention of things that are around
us so we're we're we're projecting what
we think that person wants by the way
it's behaving so we're trying to
determine whether it's a threat or
whether it's safe whether it's one on
our side or against us that kind of
thing so ultimately what we're looking
for with like with with dialog is we're
trying to see if we can believe them and
the most interesting characters are
completely unaware of what's actually
driving them you know like they're the
whole time like Indiana Jones is going
through all of these ridiculous hoops
not really like the whole time we're
wondering like why is he taking on these
Nazis why is it being dragged by a chair
just so that like some something and
make it into a museum ultimately he has
this really you know stuff that depends
how deep you want to go with Indiana
Jones but he has this kind of drive to
it it's genuinely emotionally upsetting
to him that there would be some betrayal
some misrepresentation of the truth and
that's what's interesting is so like the
whole time he's making all these really
bold choices you think he's kind of this
glib sarcastic professor but um what
he's really doing is he's trying to
unearth truth and he's trying like he's
literally putting his body under all his
brutality because he wants to the truth
to be revealed and that's you know and
every single choice you know that
because every single choice whether he
admits it or not has led toward him
exposing the truth for what it is
the other thing about good dialog is
that it beats around the bush nobody
ever comes right out and says something
instead what they do is they hint at
things and so that ends up being subtext
and subtext is dialogue plus action it's
never only the dialogue usually dialogue
plus action so if I am sitting in a
cinema seat and there is a and ice then
my de line of dialogue is can I sit here
is that okay if I sit here that line of
dialogue changes meanings if it's a
gigantic huge you know ex-convict with
tattoos all over them or if it's an
attractive member of the opposite sex
but the same line of dialogue has two
different meanings there because of the
situation and one of the things you want
to do is again that's the dialogue is
not carrying the story there it's it's
part of the visual and the verbal is a
movie but characters often hint around
two things I never come right out and
say them and that's good dialogue too
because if you think about characters as
like I like to think about it it's a
first date you're on a first date you
aren't going to immediately ask so you
ever been married you divorced instead
what you do is say well you know how do
you feel about you know something that's
that seems neutral and it's the neutral
way to get the information you ask
questions like you never asked so how do
you feel about equal rights and
responsibilities when really what you
want to ask is you just ordered this
lobster plate it's gonna smacks up my
credit card would you could this be
Dutch you know you sort of hint around
it things and that's how people really
talk or at least that's what seems real
on film as if characters don't come
right out and say things if they hint
around and that again comes with once
they hit around the audience either
knows or does not know what the reality
is and so we get either infirmity we're
learning information from how they
respond to the hints or we already know
information that we're going they're
trying to hide this this information we
all have our hidden agendas no matter
what it is if we're on the first date or
hidden agenda is learning as much about
that other person as we can to figure
out if there's gonna be a second date
and so we're always trying to feel out
the situation by sort of trying to find
the neutral question that gives us the
information if possible so we may not
come up with a direct question we'll
find the indirect way to find that
information so that's like a subtext
element thing take a simple line go
ahead drink it right so go ahead drink
it is the text okay we can add different
subtext to it so if I say
drink it there's a different subtext I'm
sure maybe threatening you right I say
go ahead drink it right I'm saying I
don't really care what you do if I say
go ahead [ __ ] drink it right I change
the text a little bit but the subtext is
totally different now so that's text
than subtext context is we're sitting in
a bus I'm holding a gun this is a clumsy
way I'm holding a gun and you're holding
poison and I'm holding your child so now
the context is extremely loaded and the
choice that you're about to make is
implicit and I'm saying if you don't
drink it I'm gonna shoot your baby so I
say go ahead drink it see the context is
this story the context is a situation
you're dealing with we can come up with
a much better that's just that comes in
my head kinda makes it but the idea is
that basically like the text is the
ironically because writers tend to
overemphasize dialogues so much the text
tends to get too much importance the
most important stuff is the context and
the subtext because the subtext is the
intention the context is the conflict
that you're dealing with the situation
you're trying to deal with so if we're
in space and we're flying toward the
moon and we know that gravity I don't
know as we go if we're flying toward the
moon and we know that this is that the
only thing that's going to save us is
this little serum and it could either
boil our blood or it might save our
lives and we've just given up and we've
been through this whole journey and we
were about to open the hatch and I say
go ahead drink it then we open the hatch
it totally changes the whole context so
that the context is about the situation
you're dealing with subtext is intention
texts is just the artifacts it's one
expression of that desire
finding the character's voice you know
one of the mistakes a lot of
screenwriters make is that they all the
all the characters sound exactly alike
well you want each character to sound
unique to themselves you know ideally if
you covered up the character's name and
read the line you would be able to tell
that it was that specific character
because they should have a specific
voice
another thing about dialogue is think
about how dialogue is character based it
all comes from characters and if you
take a different group of people and
have them say things they're gonna say
it in different ways and one of the
things that I always use as my example
is I write a lot in Starbucks coffee
shops where all the baristas are dressed
the same they all have the same basic
dialogue what will you be having room
for cream etc but each one is an
individual and the spin they put on it
their attitude comes out through the way
they say things so there is a barista at
one of my Starbucks who puts the
positive spin on everything so if you
come in and say I lost my job today
she'll say great you can spend more time
with your family no matter how bad your
life is she puts the positive spin on
everything and she is so upbeat and
chipper that I just want to kill her but
but that's her spin there is a barista
who everything is about himself so if
you come up and say I want you know the
tea with two shots of melon he goes
melons not very good I like the berry
syrup the berry syrups better with this
drink and it's like how is Howard's this
has become about you no matter what you
say he turns it into his story and so
there are carry these are these Opie all
these people have the same dialogue the
same basic dialogue but how they say it
well they're spin they put on it it
shows their character through you know
the same basic dialogue but the spin on
it and so think about character think
about dialogue as being the extension of
character and how we're gonna learn
about that character through however
they say they're you know the generic
line is this now our job as writers is
to take the generic line and do the
specific to character line you know this
character thinks this this character
believes that everything is sexual if
you know what I mean
you know and there's that barista the
does that there's the barista that you
know no matter what you the opposite of
the pepper you know whatever no matter
what you do it's always a terrible day
for them there's the there's the barista
that thinks that everyone's out to get
them it's the paranoid barista it's like
you know so you know why are you asking
about whether we have you know and it's
like all these are different characters
and they come out through basically the
same pieces of dialogue set in different
ways so think about how the character
comes out through dialogue and that
makes it individual and and interesting
you know the instead of saying the
normal line we now have the little spin
on the line which makes it a better line
of dialogue hopefully you created a
unique enough character or a character
with an with a strong enough sense of
who they are or what they're you know
how you would describe that character
and what their journey is gonna be
emotional journey is going to be that
the words kind of they kind of they
don't write themselves necessarily but
they but but it's it's like the track
that the train is running on so so you
know you you know what the characters
about you know where they're gonna go
you know what they're doing right you
know what they're doing wrong and and
and what you want them to be and how
they talk needs to match that basis of
who they are if you get the note that
all your characters sound the same first
of all you get a look at the attitude
the other things to look at are things
like characters vocabulary because you
don't want all of your characters to
have the same vocabulary that you do
each each character has different words
for things common words are the main
thing to look at character says yes no
right wrong all the words that pop up
again and again and you need to find the
individual way for each character to say
things so one character might say no
another character might say nope no
siree and these things are getting
character related you look at the
character go how would this character
say no and what I usually do is I'll
generate a list of yes knows Truffaut
any words is gonna pop up again again
and then find the one that is that
character and go okay he's saying it
this way this also comes up with curse
words can I curse in this oh you may
awesome
so curse words are one of those things I
found of my favorite curse word is [ __ ]
because I wrote a script and then when I
was reading through it I found out that
when
or anything goes wrong with any of my
characters they open their mouths and
[ __ ] comes out and so I thought that's
not possible they can't all beat me so
what I wanted to do is individualize
their curse words so I went through the
script and found different ways for them
to curse and each character had their
own distinctive curse and when I came to
one of the characters name was Carter I
just off the top of my head came up with
Kitty crap that's just kiddy crap and
when I used kitty crap I went this now
changes that character into something
even better than it was so I went back
and made him he was a surfer dude and
now I made him a southern surfer dude
which I don't think I've ever seen on
screen and so now he has sort of these
weird phrases that are like you know
down-home phrases and surfer language
all at once and so I thought that makes
us a totally individual character but
word choice is one of those things where
we each have our different vocabulary
and so that's gonna come out another
thing about dialogue is that we all
speak differently there are characters
that you know put in a word like you
know every few words you know and like I
don't know like and those things which
you use a little sparingly but
nonetheless create a different rhythm
for that character if you look at Yoda
Yoda is the most messed up sentence
structure ever because he speaks
backwards but he speaks backwards and
there's you know there's memes that are
like Yoda memes that have like the
backwards Yoda talk and that's such a
distinctive type of dialogue if you can
come up with dialogue like that there
will be people that will write that
stuff and you'll know it's Yoda right
away and that's what you want to do is
basically come up with dialogue that has
a sentence structure kind of a thing use
of like pet words like like or you know
or whatever a different vocabulary for
common words and also different
vocabulary maybe education has has
differences one of the things I love
about Elmore Leonard novels is he takes
guys who've done a lot of time in prison
and they read in prison so they have
vocabularies that are much better than
any of the cops because they've had a
lot of time to do some reading so he has
these characters who have just like
amazing vocabularies who are crooks
which makes them interesting characters
but it makes sense because you know a
lot of prison time to read so again
their vocabularies are better than the
cops the thing that I love about when
you're reading at Elmore Leonard novel
is when he goes to a character the
description part is written in that
characters voice so he just jumps into
that character and you're already seeing
the world through that character's eyes
before we get to them speaking and it
already is in their voice I don't know
what that has to do with anything but
it's cool
if you watched justified there's there's
a great example of an educated criminal
because that guy you know is the
smartest cleverest again clever a
criminal thing you know but he's he's
he's smart he's clever he can i'll talk
people with his amazing vocabulary which
is better than mine with it which is
another thing when you're the writer you
don't have to have you know all these
words you just have to know how to look
them up i like to talk a lot about
contrast so we have two characters in
the scene it's really always more
interesting if the characters are
contrasted so if a character is speaking
in a formal way so somebody was an
academic or a professor or doctor a nice
piece in a formal way make sure that the
person that he's interacting with speaks
in a more slangy way or you know more
contracted way because that's gonna make
you're gonna create that contrast you
know just like in painting if you you
want to highlight the color blue you
surround it with yellow right it's
opposite so it's the same thing with
characters a lot of the techniques in in
the dialogue chapter in the book are
about individuality how do you create
individual voices cuz having all the
characters sound the same is a very
common problem with dialogue it's
usually the writers voice and you know
and you know Sorkin has actually been
criticized for that that all these
characters sound the same but you know
when I when I talk about his dialogue
and I show clips and actual scripts you
can show that you know he actually does
individualize and the characters sound
different so it's an unfair criticism
but but you have to do that you know it
helps if if there's some you know
difference in in character speech or
cadence or contractions versus you know
stilted writing grammatically correct
training I think what you always want to
look for as a writer is if you've got
two or more characters in the scene you
want to create a situation where they
want opposing things or or because
otherwise there's no conflict or one way
to look at it is every scene is a power
grab everybody wants to take control of
the situation in what
way that means to them and so how are
they sort of secretly jockeying for
position you know like he and I do like
which of us we're all just worried we're
worried about which of us looks smarter
see that's what this whole interview has
been the other thing that you said about
the quite the the desires on the part of
the character I was thinking I know you
said there's a lot more than two but two
more I would think about as the writer
besides what were the two you said what
does the character well know that the
two different objectives yeah basically
what I broke it down to Michael is what
I call the public objective right in
other words if I asked fact anybody in
this room now what what are you doing
here what do you want what's your
objective right now we could talk about
we're doing this interview
that's our public objective then there's
underneath a deep underneath is a
private objective which may not even be
recognized well yeah that's what I was
it may be in the unconscious what's
driving that character to try to do that
right and one way I would look at it
it's not quite the same as a desire is
to ask what is the character hiding from
the other person consciously what is she
hiding from him and what is she hiding
from herself what's the thing that she's
not yet aware of that is really driving
her and you know underneath especially
in the first half or 3/4 of the movie
towards the end you'd hoped that all
that would come to the surface but
deception and secrecy are very very
powerful in telling a story because they
add a whole new layer of conflict they
get into this inner journey stuff and
they'll and the more conflict on the
more layers the more you're gonna pull
in your audience that's good I like the
hiding thing I see because I was into
that yeah there's subconscious or the
unconscious or the you know unaware of
but the hiding and deception is secrecy
that's great I'm gonna steal that can I
steal the oh sure
I'll get yours thank you no I'll you can
still use it I mean I've got taking it
forever
okay you want to share it you don't want
to steal it no I'm not gonna stay yeah
I'm not gonna clear that my job is to
look better I'll give you credit for it
okay good okay because we know my stated
objective is to look smarter I think we
yes and I'm not trying and I'm trying to
help you with I appreciate that I'll
help you think you're winning thank you
let's move on
that was great let's move on
a lot of writers don't realize you know
they're so interested in story and you
know how may I doing that you know not
to to end it instead of thinking of how
would this person express themselves in
this situation to make me feel that I'm
part of this scene so that I could put
myself in their place and feel what
they're doing through the words I would
just add that that that is what drafting
is for because if one draft you're gonna
be focused on the story and then maybe
when you've got the story you're gonna
look at word choice and another draft
and then you're gonna look at the
dialogue and you know really polish the
dialogue by and large you write a script
you turn it in you get notes they'll and
then then the notes come with dialogue
issues I don't understand this line this
isn't funnier love that line this works
this doesn't you know could you add a
little bit put a little twist on it
that's duplicated you know that kind of
thing
but which is very helpful and it's all
like I look at the scripts it's just
this big piece of clay that you know
you're constantly molding and shaping
and you know it's just sort of moving
with and trying to find the shape to it
and until you have your you know the
piece of pottery that you're trying to
make you know it's it's a lot a lot of
changes you know they always say they
say the writing is rewriting you know
and that's really you know and that's so
important you know I'm a big believer in
rewriting I'm fine about rewriting as
long as it makes sense and that it's not
just to do it to because you do make
things better you can't get it on one
fell swoop at least I can you know you
you have to write and rewrite and sort
of really work on it and let think about
it and get some distance from the
material to you know so that you can
sort of look at it with your own fresh
eyes and you have a much better sense of
what works and what doesn't work one of
the best questions you can ask yourself
for every single line of dialogue in
your scene so write the dialogue first
draft just do what you want to do don't
worry about that but when you reread the
dialogue ask yourself for every line why
is that character saying this why is the
character saying that specific line most
of the time will be because they're
responding to what so they're reacting
to something that's fine but a lot of
the times you will find that a character
is saying something because you want the
character to say that not because the
character
something in let's see another specific
time so you got to know what the
character wants and then every line of
dialogue is a strategy for that
character to get what they want and if
that dialogue is not that then you
rewrite the line until it fits that
in the 70s and 80s talk differently in
the 90s and the lows you know I mean it
it's it's over the four days of 50s it's
all very different but the basic
community of communicating you know
having clear interesting words that lead
you to a particular point that's always
what you know it is it's how you get
there it's been a little bit different
and writing anything I've written that's
had a interest on I wrote a Christmas
movie for Hallmark a few years ago and
and there were flashbacks to the 1920s
and I had a write dialogue that was
seemed about right for the 1920s and it
was just cadence you know it was just
being a little bit more formal you know
a little bit more on the nose maybe with
some of the things that were said and it
was fine you know and it's just I think
it worked you know I mean it wasn't
about using is using going back and
saying now what word did they use in the
1920s for you know automobile you know
it was something I mean it wasn't that
it was just it was a feeling it was a
texture to the words so that can be
really fun you know because we don't
know exactly know how people talked I
mean yes we have movies from back then
and we can see but we're still filtering
those things through it through a
contemporary perspective so it's not
gonna be quite like it was back then and
you want people to be able to relate to
it and understand it as a guy with gray
in my hair you know one of the problems
often is is my vocabulary is different
than current you know 15 to 25 year old
vocabulary and so part of that is you
kind of have to remain a little current
into what's going on in the world and
you know listen to slang that there's
there's two theories on slang and one is
to basically keep current with what's
how people are speaking which whether
that is actually going down to the mall
with your two people go to a mall
anymore
that's probably that's dated right there
so but anyway go down to wherever the
young people go into your skate park you
know and record people and figure out
what the slang is or the other way to do
it is the clueless version where you
create your own slang because that way
if you create slang for today for
today's
youth then that film slang doesn't work
in for tomorrow's youth its jeepers you
know it's like you know it doesn't work
but clueless decided that they were
gonna take they were gonna create their
own slang so that it would be even
though it doesn't really work cuz that's
he's totally Baldwin now has no meaning
whatsoever but basically they created
their own slang for that movie and by
creating their own slang they came up
with something that we hadn't heard
before so that also made it more
interesting dialogue but really you if
you're if you're a writer and you're
writing for today's audience you have to
sort of it still still know what today's
audience sounds like and that deals with
stories as well just the story concepts
because you know it's like I I know a
writer who's my age who is still writing
movies for Julie Andrews and and that's
never gonna happen you know it's like
you can write you can write for the past
in the past unless you have a time
machine you can't sell that script for
me
I grew up watching 70s movies and gritty
70s movies are great but I don't own a
time machine
I can't go if I wrote one I can't really
go back and sell it so even though I
still might write one of those just for
my own personal you know those are tough
sales they're they do everyone so well
pop through and I think part of that
ends up being there based on a novel so
you lose it killing me softly what the
hell is the name know that there's a
Brad Pitt movie my memories all gone but
there's like a seventh there was a
recent 70s film that was somehow made
today
and it was a crime film it was totally
hit the gritty feel at the you know the
same sort of a 70s feel but those are so
few and far between writing for the
wrong time period is a mistake
good dialog writers also have really
good ears and they're listening for the
way people speak and and they remember
those sorts of things hearing things
writing things down writing down
expressions like oh my god what a great
expression what does that mean I'm gonna
take that you know or it just the
dynamic between people you know kinds of
relationships who's talking to who at
the supermarket listening to a couple
arguing or or being too nice to each
other or whatever it is you know it's
fascinating I'm always writing things
down listening to how people talk
[Music]
listening to interesting people around
how they talk and then once you write
your dialogue read it out loud you know
do a table read with friends or your
writers group or just even if you read
it out loud yourself listening to
readings I find readings incredibly
valuable workshopping and films and TV
should be done the same way actors are
not shy about telling you what doesn't
work for them just like singers are not
shy about telling a songwriter hey you
know when I land on that it doesn't go
the words don't go with the notes sort
of a simple answer to your question
though is read your dialogue aloud yes
very good point and I don't know you can
start using a world that that's not
coming off my tongue very easily I don't
think I want to ask somebody to say that
you know when composers compose and
you're writing for an orchestra and you
don't know how to play the French horn
and you can't play the oboe and quite
often after it's done you have people
play through the parts and they say
that's unplayable you can't finger it
that way and they have to go back and
they have to change their parts because
they're not writing for that instrument
right now where we're reading through
the play we might directors dividing the
play into beads and sections and and
we're really focusing on yeah after
we've read through it all together now
we're focusing on the individual words
and to see exactly what's working and
you know what what words really don't
quite make sense so what what did I have
in my mind that the actresses aren't
necessarily feeling or getting or they
don't quite know how to say it or the
director isn't sure and that's
an amazing process you know it's like a
fantastic process so being able to hone
the words it's kind of rare you know
dude just it just only a table read of
your script before something is produced
which doesn't always happen is really
really helpful you have to hear other
voices of the ones in your head you know
you have to hear them say the words have
actors read it out loud I mean they
don't have to be professional actors but
just you and a friend read it out loud
listen to how it flows I think that can
be really helpful people think for
example that objectivity in the world
exists but it doesn't if if three people
walk into this room would they all see
the same thing it's he chairs rug desk
know if an interior designer was to walk
in this room they would get nauseous if
a carpenter came in they'd be looking at
the shelves plumb if a psychologist came
in they'd be looking at the titles of
the books and if a chiropractor came in
they'd be looking at our posture and
saying I see money coming my way
slouching but the the eye doesn't tell
the brain what it sees the brain tells
the eyes what to look for and so they I
didn't know that and so actors are
constantly looking at when they're
seeing any extreme and behavior they're
paying attention to the littlest things
you know it's not just that his voice
raises but what's he doing with his
hands while he's doing it
how is this posture changed it's gonna
use that and so again the same thing
good writers when they hear people talk
they're saying did that person get
tongue-tied when she got really angry or
did this whole slew of stuff just come
rolling off the tongue and does this
sound like something she said a lot of
times or is this something that you know
is she saying it legato or staccato you
know it's like I'm so angry you I could
just bust or is it I'm so angry at you
all right cook just bust and you all
these things they're listening for these
things saying wow listen how the
emotions coming out in every
people doing stuff that's the way I want
to write the dialogue so it's you look
at what you're interested in and if
you're a good dialogue writer you don't
just think of what words they're gonna
say it's what have I seen people do when
they're trying to demonstrate them when
they're demonstrating that emotion how
do the words come out pay attention the
world around you and you know I
something I watch I'll watch the movie
or something on TV or whatever and and
I'll look at like the the the the run of
dialogue who speak Manama
phenomenal speech you know and it by you
know phenomenal piece of dial you know I
loved the newsroom there and so I can
show the HBO show and and you know I
would literally just like just look at
it just play back over and over though
certain sections of that show and and
the way that dialogue was constructed
and you know he's such a genius in terms
of constructing dialogue and the word
that he has is people use but you can
learn so much from that you can be so
inspired and and then put your own voice
into that kind of thing and again a lot
of a lot of writing dialogue is cadence
and and personality and and things like
that and trying to have characters sound
different you know so that not every
character sounds exactly the same you
know you give every character their own
voice which is tricky it's hard to do
but but that's that's also really
important and you have to create a
little bit of you have to create
character you know beneath you know
character that's that's kind of driving
that dialogue for that even if it's just
the you know about a supporting
character somebody we don't see very
much but yeah you kind of you got to pay
attention to what's around you it's you
know the best things are out of reality
when you are doing a very contained like
a low-budget that has a lot to do with
it too because a lot of times the people
are sitting and talking right you're in
a room you're in a house or whatever so
they're sitting and talking but I think
making sure that that pacing is good so
it just doesn't feel like really you
know people just explaining things
that's kind of the death of people's
dialogue is when people over explain and
they don't know how to sort of weave in
that that exposition kind of nicely then
it really just kind of like hangs there
that's that's not good writing I think
the biggest mistake is is over
explaining and not knowing how to tunnel
the background of the story into the
story instead of laying it out like we
just developed a brilliant screenplay
the last several years in which the
opening conversation just is not
convincing because there is no other
explanation for the words in the
conversation other than explaining to
the audience what's going on and and
that's a hard to avoid mistake because
you know you've got to explain what's
going on but if you do it overtly the
audience is gonna not believe the
dialogue they're not going to believe
you know they're gonna not be able to
suspend their disbelief so you have to
sneak these things in to the story at
times when they're needed and not too
much too soon one of the common mistake
the the root mistake beneath that
mistake is thinking that the audience is
not as smart as they are it's it's
looking down on your audience there's
ways to make sure the exposition and
your dialogue matches the objective for
example if if you know I'm suspected of
murder and you're you're the you know
detective who's asking me questions
right and tell me where were you and I
didn't commit the murder
well whatever I'm gonna say is my desire
to make you think I didn't do the murder
so there's an there's a reason why I'm
saying that line I didn't do it I was at
the movies
saying at the movies
position but it's connected to my desire
to convince you that I was not the
killer you see so the exposition matches
the objective of the character you know
so there's ways to do this displaying it
you know there's techniques to make sure
the exposition is settled you know part
of a part of conflict part of your
desire line etc there's a lot of stuff
you could do but that's the lesson you
really have to know that's the that's
the most important thing make sure you
know what every character once in the
scene make sure that what they say
matches that objective so I always bring
out David Mamet was you know genius at
dialogue and he said once nobody says
anything unless they want something so
unless you want something nobody says
anything because nobody's gonna say you
know hey I'm a trustworthy character
right I mean if somebody said that to
you you're not gonna you gonna be
thinking whoa why is he telling me this
right there's always a reason why so
there's always a reason and if we know
what the reason is in the movie if you
know what the character wants or you're
trying to figure out what the character
want that's more interesting then
somebody dumping exposition you know
characters would just dump exposition
it's just boring because it's not it's
not connected to a desire line even
characters who disagree with each other
even though that might be kind of
interesting because there's some tension
there if if we don't know what they want
it's gonna be boring
so you see you see this a lot with
amateur scenes of people like oh I need
a conflict so my characters are just
gonna argue and so you have the people
arguing back and forth but it doesn't
doesn't mean anything it's just right
because we don't know what they want
that's really what makes something
interesting is intention and obstacle to
that on-the-nose dialogue could be one
of the worst I like to say sometimes
that Talking Heads dialogue where it's
just two characters talking to each
other kind of add each other and then
Q&A sessions are the worst and that's
where one character keeps asking another
questions and then they just keep
answering it so it's almost like an
interview and if that goes on for too
long it really tires out the reader and
it just gets really what we
minoes it makes Crips awful is when
characters tell you everything so
examples are if a husband and a wife
let's say a wife saw her husband having
lunch with another woman that she didn't
know about and he comes home from work
he's like hi honey how's your day and
she were to say what she'll probably say
in real life is it nothing with that
kind of you know I mean Matthew waters a
master of the subtext I recommend
looking at just about any episode of Mad
Men but much less interesting so or she
might say that the husband comes in and
says what did you do today and I was in
a similar situation once with and I did
not say I saw you with another woman
having lunch today I wanted him to like
I wanted to maybe catch him in a lie I
said or actually like well I you know
what did she do today and he said
nothing special really did you have
lunch somewhere interesting what are you
talking about and like maybe one of the
things that I loved is that if you
really play along with that you can also
play with the audience in terms of them
thinking oh yeah he was having an affair
then we find out that it was an interior
decorator and he was surprising his wife
by he just bought a little vacation home
and he was making sure that or you just
like was renting in Malibu a place and
he wanted to make sure all this stuff
was special for their anniversary and
then what can happen is if she keeps
testing him and testing him and and she
like starts bringing up old stuff about
how he pisses her off that scene could
end with him not telling her what the
surprise was and the couple deciding you
never trust me you know what I was gonna
do something nice with for you and screw
you I want a divorce I'm
just the spinning here and I'm not
saying that that's you know they the
greatest scene but that's an example of
when you play with subtext versus
characters saying everything that
they're thinking another example if you
take streetcar named desire with Blanche
and Stanley and Stella and if you had
Blanche saying well I really have been
working as a prostitute and I'm
depressed and I have nowhere else to
live game over like not very interesting
so if you think about it in those terms
yeah it's and it's really reflecting how
people are in real life people don't
always say exactly what they're thinking
and feeling you find that when you start
writing dialogues sometimes the
characters talk differently than you
then you'd expect that evolves you know
and that and that can be very
interesting and sometimes your character
changes as a result of your dialogue but
by and large you know that you know it's
we're using our voices we're using
voices of people we know we're using
Cadence's we're using regional you know
words you know it's it's a combination
of a lot of things but it does in a way
it does write itself you know you're
you're the driver but you know it does
kind of roll out but again a dialogue
you know it's about how do you write
natural dialogue how do you how do you
write the way people really speak and
it's cadence and it's it's it's
simplicity of words it's it's you know
expressing saying the most imagine that
the most amount of ideas and the least
amount of letters basically at least
amount of words and to keep it all
moving forward there's this thing like a
bumper sticker
actually I don't call it Pat Patrick
Shane Duncan who wrote courage under
fire and mr. holland's opus calls it
bumper sticker dialogue and so what it
is is it's he wrote he did some rewrite
work on a Chuck Norris movie and he
didn't get credit on-screen but everyone
has the bumper sticker that says if I
want your opinion I beat it out of you
and he wrote that line and so if you
come up with those lines go go ahead
make my day you know and all those
things that'll end up on a bumper
sticker or a t-shirt you know those are
the gold we're looking for and in the
film noir class I did out of the past
just has a line after line after line
you go you could engrave that on a bar
of gold and it would increase the value
and you know if we can come up those
lines that are clever that people
remember